Joker, the much-anticipated new take on the
DC Comics villain of the same name, weaves
such a winding narrative that it leaves behind
plenty of fascinating implications, and huge
questions, after the credits roll.
Spoilers ahead.
Let's get this one out of the way first.
Arthur Fleck spends a lot of time lost in
fantasy.
We see this almost immediately in the film,
when he's watching Murray Franklin and fantasizes
about being an audience member who gets called
down in front of the cameras.
Later, this goes even further when we realize
that Arthur has imagined an entire romantic
relationship with his neighbor Sophie.
This tendency toward fantasy, coupled with
things like the dreamlike way he walks out
of the interview room in the final shot of
the film, are enough to make us wonder how
much of the story takes place in Arthur's
head.
We know for sure that some elements are imagined,
but what else might be?
Did he ever actually make it out of that cop
car in the middle of the riot?
Did he actually kill his therapist?
Was he even, perhaps, in the asylum the whole
time?
It's hard to be certain, but the rest of these
questions rely on at least some of these events
being true.
Arthur Fleck's life is unraveling from pretty
much the moment Joker begins, but things only
get worse when he learns that his mother Penny
believes that Thomas Wayne, her former employer,
is Arthur's father.
At first, Arthur has no reason to believe
his mother is wrong, but when he confronts
Wayne about it, the billionaire insists that
Penny is just delusional.
Later, Arthur recovers paperwork from Arkham
State Hospital that apparently confirms that
he was adopted, but is that the whole story?
Even later in the film, he finds a photograph
of his mother that Thomas Wayne apparently
inscribed on the back with a comment about
Penny's lovely smile... so how much of the
Wayne story was really true?
Joker is a film that keeps most of its very
precise focus on Arthur Fleck and his very
small life, but he's accidentally a catalyst
for a much larger picture.
He tells Murray Franklin that he doesn't consider
himself political, but the subway murders
he commits spark a sweeping political movement,
and by the end of the film, that movement
considers him its leader, cheering at his
feet in the streets of a burning Gotham.
While this de facto Joker Gang was founded
on anti-rich sentiment amid worsening conditions
for the working class in Gotham City, by the
end of the film their protests have turned
into full-on riots.
This begs the question: are they ever actually
able to achieve anything?
Does the murder of someone as important as
Thomas Wayne drive them back into the shadows...
or do they become more active than ever?
A key subplot in Joker follows Thomas Wayne's
campaign to become mayor of Gotham City, and
his criticisms of the demonstrators who revere
the subway shooter.
Wayne is portrayed in the film as a powerful,
blustery man who happens to be sitting atop
the powder keg that is Gotham City politics,
and he's more than just a little oblivious
to the lives of the less fortunate.
But no matter how out of touch Thomas Wayne
is, why on earth would he take his wife and
young son to a movie theater in the middle
of Gotham on the night of a planned protest
against the rich?
And even if he did want to take that risk,
why didn't he at least have a driver waiting
to escort them out?
Whether courageous or just clueless, it seems
like a really bad time to go to the movies
when you've got a perfectly good mansion to
chill in.
There have been many similar versions of Batman's
origin story, but they all involve the death
of Bruce Wayne's parents, whether they're
gunned down by a random mugger, or a guy specifically
named Joe Chill or Jack Napier.
In Joker, the Waynes are killed by a random,
clown-masked rioter who happens to have a
gun, but there's no way Bruce Wayne won't
later learn that the whole ordeal happened
because of Arthur Fleck.
With that in mind, is Batman's eventual mission
to fight crime cast in a different light?
It's no longer just "crime" that killed his
parents; it's the violent movement surrounding
Joker.
In this world, does Bruce Wayne still become
Batman, or does his mission change?
Will he focus on Arthur Fleck exclusively?
And if he does become Batman, how does knowing
what he knows about Arthur change him?
Arthur Fleck is at first reluctant to embrace
the violence within him, but by the end of
Joker, the dam has clearly broken.
"All I have are negative thoughts."
Arthur is no longer interested in holding
himself back, from killing Murray Franklin
on live TV, to murdering the therapist interviewing
him at Arkham.
As the film ends, Arthur's potential escape
is left up in the air.
Because he's the Joker now, we can reasonably
assume that he did manage to get out of Arkham
that day, and is on the loose again after
the credits roll.
If that happened, what's his purpose now?
Who does he go after next?
His mother's old abusive boyfriend, or his
birth parents?
Or will he become like the comic book version
of the Joker, and simply act as an agent of
chaos, pursuing random bloodshed?
Whatever he does, it won't be pretty.
Gotham City is a metropolis teetering on the
brink even before Arthur Fleck's rampage.
It's dirty, covered in graffiti, and mountains
of garbage are piling up amid a strike while
super rats stalk the darker parts of town.
It's a city infested with crime, unemployment,
and anger.
The rise of Arthur and those who sympathize
with him only makes things worse.
It all seems to culminate in the murders of
Thomas Wayne and Murray Franklin, but surely
that's not where it ends.
With Thomas Wayne dead, the divide between
the privileged and the underprivileged in
Gotham could deepen very quickly.
The police could crack down even harder on
people who don't deserve it, and the Joker
Gang could respond with even bigger, more
violent riots.
The city is on edge, and it won't have Batman
to come to the rescue for at least another
decade.
So what does Gotham do?
How does it cope?
There's no easy answer.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.